he is part of College GameDay which will
be emanating from the Ohio State
University at the horseshoe taking on
Penn State that's a big game certainly
based on the fact of the top seven teams
in the college football playoff rankings
that just came out last night is the
same as the previous week he is David
Pollock from the worldwide leader in
sports how are you David great I am
doing fine so run it back basically is
what the college football playoff
rankings committee essentially said I'm
wondering what you take out of the
latest rankings
well obviously run it back for this week
I think Alabama in a predicament you
know you look at all the teams around
them
obviously Georgia has an awesome chance
in a couple of weeks with LSU to to make
a big statement Ohio State is still very
much in control of its own destiny LSU
in control that's a Clemson and
controllers knows that's good you got
organ and you tall we're gonna play each
other in a couple weeks at Alabama I
think this week we don't learn a lot but
about Alabama in their future but
without two and not playing another
marquee game you know Auburn will be a
good game to prove something you know
Alabama is in that spot right now at
five and Georgia obviously could slip up
to LSU as I see cancer game but I felt
like Alabama's a team when you look at
the team that's got seven that's not
really in control of their own destiny
though so are we in a similar situation
I guess we're the Alabama then I guess
maybe Ohio State from the year that they
won at all we were all wondering if they
should even go because their starting
quarterback wasn't there and Cardale
Jones showed us all of that do you think
Alabama might actually be pointing to
that Ohio State team and it's all said
and done saying they deserve a shot this
bite - of being hurt I think they will
but that was also the Big Ten
championship game and one of the
criteria for the committee they talked
about is you know head to head and they
talked about a conference championship
so Alabama won't have that opportunity
and they're not gonna be in the game
it's gonna be good aubergines don't get
me wrong and and they'll have Matt Jones
and a chance to make a big statement I'm
a 59 or nothing with Cartel chosen Ohio
State so it'd have to be something you
know monumental but more importantly I
think they're just they're gonna need
some help I think they're gonna be in a
tough situation but if they look really
really good because which was the resume
you point to with Alabama every
committee talks about what I guessed and
rightfully so and here's the thing who
would be if I Manila's you said first of
all I didn't want to see Bama again I
don't want to see if they play ten times
with two in the ball game
I think Alabama wins at least five of
those games you know I think you got a
five five whatever you could tell he was
banged up you could tell he was limited
so the committee you could tell had a
little leeway and music but now you know
Mack Jones would have to look phenomenal
and then like that like you said that
game it has to be still need other teams
to lose because they still would be a
chance to win accomplished championship
David Pollock here on the Rich Eisen
show so then why why Alabama five I mean
if we're sitting here saying they might
not have the resume for it and we're
sitting here and saying that they're not
gonna play in the SEC championship game
we're we're virtually assure of that and
why are they above the team that will
most presumably be your pac-12 champion
are we getting a hint that hey pac-12
championship you you better be pretty
damn good and compelling to get in there
because we're assuming LSU Georgia might
not make it right
yeah well I think when you heard Rob
bones talk on the committee last night
he was talking to us rich and he said a
big deal he said we judged these games
as of right now he said Alabama when I'm
smacked around Mississippi State this
past weekend they looked great doing it
well sue it was a part of that so I
think they're judging the committee and
the teams on what they see right now and
listen I think you can make a case for
its organ that's where there's a loss to
Auburn I mean if you want to point the
stuff that's what everybody points to
they they had that game in hand they
played well they should have won that
game but they did in the size of that
they beat the Washington in Washington
State teams by about six seven points
combined you know so I think Utah
obviously losing the USC is a big big
deal Alabama this point lost LSU I mean
they look 46 with the rack being hobbled
and probably 70% 60% of what he normally
is in a pretty competitive game so I
think that's what the committee is
looking at right now and that's what Rob
bones intimated to us lifeline and how
big was that
go home and come back on Baylor I mean
that was one hell evening that was think
of me is how they did it okay this
wasn't Tyler Marie and Baker Mayfield
spinet being all over the yard and
making big-time plays Lincoln rally is a
smart enough coast to understand like
listen I'm not the same team genuine
Hertz is not that guy that can do that
what am I going to do I'm going to run
in 25 30 times and I'm gonna wear out
baylor baylor kept giving them they kept
playing very conservative in the back
end and all they did up front was
continue stand people up blue people
around you had to run the football to be
better that night lincoln rally and then
had to be conservative they played ball
control their defense played right at
the right time but I tell you what rich
it's a great win for Oklahoma but the
big 12 in trouble I mean there is I
don't mean I can't even paint a scenario
where the big 12 gets back in this over
the next couple weeks and and get to the
final in a college football playoff
position while you were you just stole
my my next question out of my mouth
because it just seems here again that
the way it's all set up
assuming Ohio State wins out clemson we
know won't get touched on us something
shocking happens let's put it that way
with Clemson or even LSU even if LSU
loses to Georgia in the SEC championship
game we're assuming they're gonna get in
even if it is a close loss which would
seal out get off the pac-12 and big 12
champions so I was gonna ask you
assuming one of them gets in which one
would you say gets in pac-12 our big 12
champ
I think the pac-12 has the best chance
of Georgia wins it kills the pac-12 and
the big 12
but Utah in Oregon sitting six and seven
and the opportunity to play each other
in several weeks down the road and make
a statement is it become a champion of
your league is a huge deal but you know
you can't have what was the worst thing
that could possibly happen would be Ohio
State losing to Minnesota like imagine
RIT imagine LSU beating Georgia and then
Minnesota beating Ohio State what the
heck are you gonna do like cousins in
Georgia's in Minnesota has to be in the
college school player now comes down to
LSU at Ohio State like that that would
be my kind of selection Sunday the last
week of the season if we got some
craziness but you know that would also
put a lot of conferences at jeopardy and
it's obviously the pac-12 in the big 12
but they they definitely the pac-12
definitely a better position in the big
12 David Pollock of ESPN College GameDay
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
for a few more minutes
I'm sure Penn State fans are raising
their hands right now saying hey well
what about this weekend here so yeah how
do you see Penn State at the Horseshoe
versus Ohio State working out David man
Penn State leaking oil I mean they're a
team that had a lot of momentum early
but it definitely struggled and I was
just watching Minnesota and Indiana
games back and looking at their defense
their defense the front seven is really
really good but they man they struggle
versus play action I think I took notes
it was like 17 and 17 rich in play
action in the last two games against
Penn State were the quarterbacks
literally were 17 or 17 and they
struggled are too aggressive in the back
end biting down and then they just
struggle in the back end period so
they're gonna have to score a lot of
points and Katie Hamlin's gonna have to
be healthy and you know they're
definitely gonna have to figure out to
get hot again they're got the fun their
mojo again they got a great defensive
front seven but you know Penn State's
not playing their best and I think Ohio
State has played consistently really
really good throughout the season so I I
think Penn State's can happen get some
some fortuitous bounces like they did a
couple years ago and make some plays and
special teams and trade
the big plays like that if they're gonna
sound totally up there well you could
make the case that halftime of Penn
State Michigan was a potentially a
turning point for both teams as you said
Penn State's leaking oil that first half
looked great and in the second half not
so much in Michigan was leaking oil
pretty much up until that halftime and
Jim Harbaugh said we're about to have
our finest hour and who knew he saw
something good coming and it has
developed do you see any shot from
Michigan in the big house against Ohio
State yes yeah absolutely I think is
playing great rich I think they're one
of the hottest teams in college football
they got a great identity offensively
and I think Michigan's the teams in
Michigan's with Michigan which struggle
with with the big physical teams because
they're amazing it's not what they used
to be up front as far as size and
quickness and speed and play making like
they were with those big old suckers and
the trenches is one of itch and Gary and
all these guys had over the last couple
years but they still got see they can
still play man coming to self good
corners they still have great speed you
know in the front seven and so I think
them and Ohio State are on a great
collision course and would it be would
it just be a fitting result just to see
Michigan maybe beat Ohio State at the
end of the season like would that just
be like last year Ohio State ruined
Michigan season at the end the year with
nobody really gave any chances this year
Michigan is gonna come in as a huge
underdog and it just seems fitting for
this rivalry that we all love to watch
every single year at the end of the
season that something like that would
happen or talk about it forever yeah
we'll see but that would obviously be a
remarkably satisfying ending for
Michigan fans to that season but first
things first you got Ohio State Penn
State this weekend obviously a.m. versus
Georgia Texas at Baylor in that regard
and I'm sure you'll be just discussing
all of that on College GameDay
last two for you David Pollock your
Heisman Trophy you hand it to burrow
right now or just chase young over the
next couple weeks coming back after a
suspension have a shot hurts weird how
do you handicap this race right now I
mean it's crazy to say that right now
and then you think about the journey
that this offense has been on but I mean
just completing their insane level of
passes and just you who complete
77% of their classes like that's nice
humid rich like that where it's hard to
do that on air like that's hard to go
out and do on a seven on seven and to be
so productive and so good in so many big
moments and every time it seemed needed
um I think he's far and away the Heisman
Trophy frontrunner it changed young
didn't get suspended let me tell you
something since the offensive line was
let me beat in the drum for him I mean
he cuz he is the most dominant player in
college football at the end of the day
what separates Clemson LSU and an Ohio
State what separates them to me it from
from being one being the top team in the
country not what a chase young one
doesn't that guys are super freak okay I
mean he can dominate a football game
defensively more than anybody and I
would've been interesting to see him not
get to spend I think in beginning sprint
and it hurts it but it's it's jobber oh
I don't I don't know how you're gonna
make it any other way [ __ ] fourth and
last one for you the most safe for work
sign that you've seen on the set of
college gameday behind you this year but
what it worked
what safe for work that you can tell me
right here on a radio show
what sign that was been brought by a
college gameday fan is in your house in
your favorite sign of the year last year
we were at Baylor it was big on quality
losses and justification by people so
there was a world war to sign and it was
it was pretty pretty creative talking
about how it was a quality loss in World
War two as opposed to being a loss that
was a that was a good one we had last
weekend so we want Bama scratched out
LSU signs are starting to take off and
be really really funny because of you
know because of the season and watching
LSU take off so those are two that think
about something David thanks for the
call appreciate it say let's say hello
to everybody
Risa's as as great as they come and just
not only us but people and Desmond and
everybody else have a good one
no problem look there thank you rich you
got that's David Pollock of ESPN College
GameDay right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app